you are a little on ago sorry welcome
back to the games on stage here at e3
2015 I enjoyed by Chuck creative
director the coalition we're gonna be
showing up some gears wall ultimate
edition uh Chuck Hayden how is your show
be oh it's been fantastic the response
for ultimate edition of them really
really good I mean so gears is obviously
this call xbox franchise like I don't
mean we could wax lyrical for so long
about how what gears has done for modern
gaming for a car works did we can have
you won um I mean let's gets get into
the ultimate edition so obviously gears
for is coming out is this kind of a way
to introduce cuz gears is gonna be ten
next year yes it's amazing isn't it I
can't wait I can't believe it I can't
believe it either I mean it's been it's
been such a privilege to be able to work
on the gears franchise obviously a year
and a half ago microsoft acquired the
license and that came to the coalition
studio up in vancouver along with that
rod fergusson who was one of the
co-creators and you know he came and
joined the studio and that's been a
godsend for us so you know the first
thing we did is is we sat down and
started to deconstruct years because you
know it's such a deceptively simple game
but you don't realize until you start to
dive into it how everything works
together so what epic created is really
elegant and it's it's one of those games
that if you don't have somebody like rod
on staff it's really hard to understand
the nuances of the experience so we you
know we spent time doing that and the
idea was while we're building gears for
which we knew is going to be a
multi-year effort how do we get
something in the hands of fans as
quickly as possible and the idea was
spawned you know to build the ultimate
edition and what we did was we actually
stripped the game all the way down to
the core code base and everything in the
game has been rebuilt from scratch so
every character every enemy every weapon
all the lighting VFX all the cinematics
and the mocap has all been redone from
scratch too so it can be one of those
premiere you know showcase products on
xbox one so have you done that like in
engine so what was the original gears
made it unreal it was uh I'm not sure
which of the honor goes one of the
unreal yeah what is this be made it
unreal for no no it's actually being
done in the in an updated version of the
Unreal Engine
oh yes that's all the original code yeah
I was gonna say I was good that was my
questions like house then T pull that
across it's the Unreal Engine is amazing
it's a really robust engine has a lot of
flexibility to it and the team is you
know we've gotten great support from
epic yeah which has been fantastic we've
been partners with them not only on this
but also on the Unreal foreign so the
relationship has been great and that's
really allowed us to do everything that
you're seeing in the game today so it's
been completely rebuilt from scratch I
mean why is that important to do I mean
because i think you know because gears
was a showcase product when it came out
and people have such great memories
about it was one of the you know the one
of the first HD games on the system it
was one of those games that you bought
to show off to your friends how awesome
the system was if you're going to bring
that to xbox one you need to maintain
the same level of quality and make sure
that it's still a showcase product so
for us it was really important not just
to go out and offer as the textures but
to really give the fans you know the
game that they deserved on xbox one
especially as the initial product that
launched another reason other thing
you're doing is the smooth 1080 60 yeah
so huh what is that gonna bring a
gameplay how's that oh it's amazing
we've got it playing on the floor and
obviously we announced on Monday after
the show that the the ultimate edition
beta was going on right now people go to
Gears of War calm sign up it's going to
run until tuesday at 11am yeah and what
the 1080p 60 frames a second has done is
just elevated to the same level as the
best multiplayer experiences on the
next-gen system so it's really fluid
really responsive it plays it plays
really really smoothly it when you pick
it up and play it it's a whole different
experience it's really amazing so which
which multiple modes are available in
the beta right now we've brought TDM
over team deathmatch over from gears 3
which wasn't available in the original
but it's the most played and most
popular multiplayer mode and we also
brought king of the hill not the one
from the original PC version but the
gears 3 version so you put thee so you
put things from Giz 3 into gears one was
that look good I mean how did that come
about was that just a thing
you know we know fans want this or is
this thing that's kind of wish this was
in the first day a little bit of both
right having rod on tap was great
because he could say look this is the
reason why we did this in the first game
either because of the technological
issues their time issues or what we just
didn't know any better right the gears
the gears franchise has evolved in every
game has gotten a little bit better and
a little bit you know has more features
in it and what you realize is when you
go back and play a game that's nine
years old you realize very quickly how
much the game has evolved over time and
the things that you're used to like
being able to switch weapons or preload
a weapon when your roadie running or
pick up a weapon before you get into the
into the active area for it it's really
important it's things that you sort of
expect so we want to make sure that
those things were able to come to
ultimate edition but not change the
essence of the experience so we spend a
lot of time with a bunch of the gears
pro gamers brought them in very early
and talk to them about one of the things
you love about the original ears one of
the things that you'd like us to add and
one of the things that you want us to
change or fix from the original so we
have a really special relationship with
our community and those guys have been
really instrumental in a lot of the
change that we put into the game because
we're really building it for the fan
base I mean it's not just how gears is
evolved over time but it's also how
other shooters and 3rd person games have
evolved yeah exciting i'm here because
everyone's kind of sparking off each
other and iterating on these themes so I
mean you guys tufted you set the
standards and everyone's kind of copying
you a little bit well I mean we all have
fond memories of games from 10 years ago
right when you go and play those in fact
we had this experience we went sat down
to play don't we were asking rod is this
a bug is this supposed to be here and he
said no that's actually supposed to be
there but in the interim when you play
these other games you start to get these
systems you start to get these features
and things that you know have evolved
and made the game better that if you
don't have in there you missed them and
that's what the fans want and that's
what the community wanted to said please
put the stuff in because we want to be
able to mark enemies and multiplayer
because it enhances the team the team
based play which is really what gears is
all about so that's a little bit about
this because I noticed you've added a
spectator mode so is this a kind of
typically I would use what we see in
eSports so we can get shout casters and
commentary is this a kind of Avenue that
gaze is gonna go down I think we'd like
to explore it I mean as I said
incredibly passionate community that's
really been running a lot of tournaments
and events on their own and this is some
of the stuff that they ask for they said
hey we want land support because when
we're setting one of these things up we
don't always have great internet
connection so we want to be able have
the best possible experience we put that
in the other thing we put into the
spectator mode so when you get a
play-by-play guy and a color commentator
they can now take two of the slots and
be able to show the action that they
want to show instead of being tied to
any of the particular players in the
match so another thing that microsoft
announced on monday in their press
conference with the new elite controller
right have you guys had a chance to use
that yeah it's amazing yeah it's by far
and away the best controller I've ever
put my hands on and the great thing
about it is it works fantastic with
gears it's completely customizable and
everything is is attached through
magnetic so if you like your stick a
little bit taller you like a round top
on it you just pop one off pop the other
one on and you get exactly experience
you want and if you haven't touched it
head over to the booth and try it out
it's got a great way right then yeah I
know I can't believe ever made it over I
know I look that was a cute I know you
get to the front of the queue shove past
people to have to kinda help you out hey
uh so let's have a look at what we can
see here so this is on the gameplay
which kinda just looks he looks
fantastic I mean thank you the honest is
on a really amazing job let's look
little Emma so you kind of got new
lighting system place you yeah um what
other small things have really made a
big difference I mean it's really just
been taking the time to rebuild
everything from scratch all right i mean
it's when you're taking stuff that
exists and you're just trying to uh
press it there's always going to be
things that don't exactly work right but
when you can take a model a character an
enemy of brew max something like that
and actually rebuild it you can sand off
all those rough edges right so you get
exactly the experience you want and
that's why the quality of it is as high
as it is you know the team of the
coalition and the team the partners that
we have it splash damage is such a done
such amazing job and they bring that
same sort of passion
that the hardcore fans in the community
have for it and for them it's not great
until you know if something we're gonna
be really proud of to put out there and
so we're not cutting any corners with
this game at all so coalition is now the
new home of gears yeah um why do you
guys change your name by the wigs you
were black tusk and then you kind of
change it to an even more badass noon
yeah I think so I mean we really like
the idea of the coalition and I think
especially when you think about
Microsoft development there's studios
like 343 and when you go to 343 you
realize okay I'm going to build Halo
games them that's what we're gonna do
same thing with turn 10 you know you're
going to get forza and you're going to
build racing experience and I think it
was important the same thing with the
coalition to to project an image of hey
where the where the stewards of the
gears of war franchise an IP and when
you come to the studio you know you need
to be a passionate gears fan you need be
somebody who wants to build the best
possible gears experience and by
changing the name to embody really what
the IP is all about which is a diverse
collection of people coming together to
make something great it felt like it was
the right thing to do and it felt like
it really was a natural a natural
selection for the studio so speaking of
funds obviously you're gonna have some
really hardcore fans who will go back
with with the franchise to the beginning
how they how was that relationship with
the studio and the the franchise evolved
over time and how they can give a get
themselves involved in terms of feedback
and things like that well obviously uh
you know actors Viking is rod fergusson
he's got a huge Twitter following and
he's always responding to everybody I'm
happy to talk to fans on Twitter you
know we have we just launched our new
gears of war calm website which has the
new forums and the ability to talk to
you know our main moderator Jack felling
& and the team up there I mean that we
really love our community and they are
passionate like nobody I've ever seen I
mean this this has been my first year
being introduced to the gears fan base
and it is unbelievable you could not ask
for a more passionate fan base than the
people who love gears and they know that
we're available for them they've been
we've had people that have been here all
three days so far just standing in the
queue playing through the beta on the
floor because they love the game so much
and we take the time to talk to them and
get their feedback and really
balance that out and figure out what the
best experience that we can deliver to
the fans is wonderful thank you so much
when can we get our hands on the gears
of war what's going on over there
against the walls of an addition well
you can get your hands on the beta today
at runs till next Tuesday and then the
game launches in stores August 25th in
the u.s. August twenty-eighth in Europe
and if you buy Ultimate Edition you
actually get access to Gears of War for
early beta and then additionally we
announced on Tuesday that we're also
supporting the pc so that's going to
have full 4k support dx12 yep unlimited
refresh rate so if you have a monster
system enjoy sure you do it plays
unbelievably and looks unbelievably as
well as having support for keyboard and
mouse the xbox wireless controller and
as we just talked about the new elite
controller so those will all work with
the pc pretty much every single bell and
whistle then that's the plan thank you
so much for joining me alright guys my
stint is sadly over i'll be back at the
end of the day I think you got Chris
waters coming up next make sure you
don't go anywhere